[Music]
by now we are aware of what exactly the
concept of atomic number and atomic mass
is atomic number is simply the number of
protons present inside the nucleus of an
atom whereas the atomic mass is the
number of protons and neutrons present
in the atomic nucleus so when we have to
represent both these entities for an
element how do we write it is there a
specific way for representing it yes
the chemical symbol of the element is
written with atomic number at its bottom
on the left side that is in subscript on
the other hand the atomic mass is
written on the top left side in
superscript something like this the
symbol of the element it's atomic number
and it's atomic mass now how do we
represent a simple elements like carbon
that's right something like this the
atomic symbol that is C followed by the
atomic number six an atomic mass 12 at
the respective places now what if it's
another element say chlorine something
like this maybe
yes one type of chlorine atom can be
represented like this why did I say one
type of chlorine atoms are there more
types of chlorine atoms yes some
chlorine atoms have 20 neutrons instead
of 18 in the nucleus then how do we
represent this type yes just like this
representation however we now need to
understand what exactly that is there
are many such cases where atoms of the
same element exist in different forms
these forms are called the isotopes yes
in simple words isotopes are defined as
the atoms of the same element having the
same number of protons but different
number of neutrons yes same number of
protons but different number of neutrons
just as we saw in the case of chlorine
all the atoms have 17 protons but a few
of them have 18 neutrons while some
others have 20 so these are the
the topic forms of chlorine similarly
several elements have isotopic forms for
instance we have carbon with three
isotopes as we can see here each isotope
has six protons but different number of
neutrons one has six the other has seven
and the last one with eight neutrons we
name these isotopes as carbon-12
carbon-13 and carbon-14 respectively now
this was about the different forms of
the same element but what if I tell you
that atoms of two different elements can
have the same atomic mass yes let's
understand this with an example we take
five different elements sulfur potassium
calcium chlorine and argon now if you
notice in each case the number of
protons and neutrons is different it's
16 and 24 here 19 and 21 here and so on
that's right
however the total number of nucleons in
each sums up to 40 what do we mean by a
nucleon a nucleon is a proton or a
neutron yes each state present in a
nucleus is a nucleon so the total number
of nucleons in an atom is the sum of
protons and neutrons we can also say
that the total number of nucleons in an
atom is it's atomic mass yes understand
this well the total number of nucleons
which is nothing but the sum of protons
and neutrons is the same as the atomic
mass of the atom so coming back to our
example there are five different atoms
here though the number of protons and
the number of neutrons is different in
each case the total number of nucleons
in each is the same which means the
atomic masses are the same how yes it's
simple math one of the sulphur isotopes
that we have taken as an example has 16
protons and 24 neutrons so the atomic
mass of this isotope has to be 40 units
that's 16 plus 24
next is the potassium isotope having 19
protons and 21 Newt
so again we get the atomic mass as four
units and similarly we get the atomic
mass as four units in each of the
remaining cases such atoms or rather
isotopes of different elements having
the same atomic mass are called as
isobars the term arises from greek ISO
meaning same and barrows meaning weight
remember if we considered two isobars
the number of protons and number of
neutrons in each case will be different
but the total number of nucleons or the
atomic masses will be the same
so far we've understood subatomic
particles and a few important concepts
related to atoms
now let's move ahead and learn the
important concept of valency in the next
lesson
[Music]
you